there is a new sign this morning that
more charges may be coming from the
investigation of Russian election
meddling lawyers for president Trump and
former national security adviser Michael
Flynn are no longer sharing information
an attorney for the retired three-star
general told the president's legal team
on Wednesday that they cannot discuss
the investigation any further one of the
president's lawyers tells CBS news Flynn
may be arranging a plea deal and other
observers say it suggests that Flynn is
turning against mr. Trump
Errol Barnett is in West Palm Beach
Florida where the president is spending
the holiday weekend Darrel good morning
good morning General Michael Flynn is a
central figure in this investigation led
by special counsel Robert Muller looking
into whether any of president Trump's
aides colluded with Russia during the
campaign and this latest development
could be a sign that Flynn is now
cooperating general Flynn is a wonderful
man I think he's been treated very very
unfairly by the media despite the
president's praising CBS News has
learned mr. Trump's legal team has been
expecting either an indictment of
Michael Flynn or his son or a plea deal
involving both stemming from special
counsel Robert mullahs Russia
investigation Mike Flynn is a fine
person and I asked for his resignation
mr. Trump fired Flynn from his post as
national security adviser just three
weeks after becoming president as
reports surfaced he misled the vice
president about his contacts with Russia
I fired him because of what he said to
Mike Pence very simple sources tell CBS
News Flynn's attorney Robert kalna told
the president's legal team on Wednesday
that no future communications could or
would occur regarding Flynn mr. Trump's
attorney Jay Sekulow said the silence
likely means Flynn took a plea deal he
went on to tell CBS News if it is a plea
that doesn't necessarily mean it has
anything to do with the president the
attorneys for Flynn and Flynn jr.
replied with no comment on Thanksgiving
at a Coast Guard Station near his South
Florida Club President Trump handed out
turkey sandwiches with First Lady
Melania Trump the press I know doesn't
have any questions if you do we won't
tank them but that's
he refused questions from the press and
used the event to brag about his
administration's accomplishments the
stock market on Friday hit the all-time
high the highest has ever been now the
president also praised the Coast Guard
at that Thanksgiving event for its
efforts during hurricane Harvey he said
something to the effect that no other
brand has gone up more than the Coast
Guard for what happened there in Texas
bianna and no response yet from the
president regarding to Flynn news Errol
thank you